are returning now to our top story in
the war in Ukraine Ukrainian forces have
regained uh territory from Russian
troops in recent uh days in a
counter-offensive that's happened uh
really quickly let's bring in hod Abdul
Hamid who's in car key for us you've
traveled with the Ukrainian Army to one
of the areas they've recently recaptured
tell us about what you saw
well indeed we traveled to a town called
balaclia which when the ukrainians
captured back on September 7th it really
meant a significant win and took
everyone here in the country by surprise
even though if you go to that town it is
quite a small town uh well we we went
through the side roads through Villages
uh and what we saw is actually a quite a
fair amount of Destruction considering
that those are remote rural Villages uh
we saw also signs of a chaotic Retreat
of the Russian army a lot of military
hardware abandoned ammunition abandoned
uh villagers did tell us that it was
they heard a lot of chaos on that they
that day being September 6th uh they saw
some Russian soldiers and they say that
among them they were also people who
were fighting on behalf of one of the
two self-propriate
republics the lugan's People's Republic
and they were trying to put on there as
civilian clothes or take off their
uniforms storming into abandoned houses
to try to find anything they could get
we didn't see the amount of Destruction
and the amount of evidence of war crimes
that was discovered when the Russians
retreated north of key even places like
Butcher and European nevertheless we did
assist to an exhumation of two bodies
that were parked in a little plot of
land at the end of of balaclia we also
were taking to the police station where
it was really really messy and chaotic
there was a lot of things left behind
papers everywhere and then the police
took us to a few cells where they were
electrical cables hanging and they were
saying that that was evidence that the
word torture we spoke to one man who
told us that indeed that happened in
that police station Hoda you've covered
this conflict conflict since the early
days in February do you get a sense that
we are at a turning point right now with
this counter-offensive from the
ukrainians
from the military
they do have the momentum uh certainly
their Spirits are high because they have
storms through large sways of lands it's
an they have taken over now or
recaptured about uh two to three hundred
settlements that is an estimated between
four to six thousand square kilometers
but this is a long battle and the
Russians still hold large part of the
country whether it's in the donbass
region or in the south in the herzon
region and one of the estimates put that
amount of land still in Russian hands
about 120
000 square kilometers and the ukrainians
do say that when it comes to equipment
when it comes to
Manpower I would say or soldiers they
are outnumbered by the Russian so yes
they have the momentum yes they are
happy with what they have but this is a
a job that is far from over and it won't
be over anytime soon now 40 in the
challenge is how long can they keep the
territory they've taken already as they
continue pushing uh what will the
Russians next move be is anyone's guess
at the moment yes they have been they
still have air superiority and Strikes
happen here in Harkin on a regular basis
on a daily basis but not only here we
heard that for example
which is in further east in the country
has also been under heavy shelling
overnight so the Russians still have
capability and at the moment we're not
getting any indication from Moscow on
what could their next move be so
certainly the ukrainians are high
spirited feel that they have the
momentum but they have a lot to do yet
thank you very much for that Al jazeers
reporting there live from car cave in
northeastern Ukraine